[Music]
hello everybody
and greetings from an unexpectedly sunny
spring day in germany
thank you very much for the kind
invitation my name is thomas metzinger
and i'm a professor of philosophy at the
university of mainz in germany
in these two presentations today i want
to try and
make you see something
you may not have seen before in current
philosophy there are two hot
topics namely the ethics the applied
ethics of artificial intelligence
and the problem of consciousness what i
want to try
today is if you can see the connection
between these two
fields of research
so in this first short talk i want to
talk about the problem
of artificial consciousness and give a
brief sketch of an argument
why we should be very careful
with implementing this
so from a 2018 to
20 i have worked in the european
commission's high level expert group on
artificial intelligence
i have co-authored the ethic guidelines
for trustworthy ai
and the policy and investment
recommendations for trustworthy
ai and it was a very interesting
experience for me i met very many smart
people
52 top level experts on ai
and i definitely learned a lot we
published our
guidelines on the 11th of april 2019 and
the policy
and investment recommendations uh on the
26th
of june however there are some bad
news these ethics guidelines were
strongly
contaminated by industrial lobby
and actually from a philosopher's point
of view
they are a lot of hot air there's no
real
normative substance there are no real
concrete recommendations and
applications and for example all red
lines
have been taken out of the final
document
i think they are also short-sighted
because they deliberately ignore some
long-term issues and here are some
examples
of issues the high-level group
deliberately ignored the problem of
artificial general intelligence the
problem
of possible possibly autonomous moral
agents
emerging and the problem i want to talk
about today
artificial consciousness or as it is
sometimes called
synthetic phenomenology alluding to
synthetic biology so here's the first
technical term
uh you have to learn i i understand some
of you
have to give go through a test at the
end of this course
so the new term is ethics washing
this is if you organize and cultivate
ethical
debates because you want to delay
postpone avoid or deter
people from policy making and
regulation so there are people who have
an interest
in these ethics debates going on
just to buy themselves time
i think what we really need and what we
urgently need
is binding rules which are also
enforceable
and which are legitimate because there
is a full democratic
process behind them
the good news however is that the
current
european ethics guidelines are much
better than anything
china or the united states actually have
and those current ethics guidelines are
also an excellent
first step a plateau to begin a second
phase of discussion and to develop them
further so what we can actually do is we
can move the discussion back
from a place where it is dominated by
industrial lobby
which just wants to decorate a major
investment strategy
by making it look ethical
into a more constructive and
intellectually honest context
maybe that is here but i will confine
myself to one single topic today
synthetic phenomenology i'm one of the
guys
that founded the association for the
scientific study of consciousness
27 years ago and i've been
working in the consciousness community
for
30 years of my life there's something
that is slightly beginning
to make me nervous there are four labs
now
on this planet with esteemed colleagues
of mine people who i really like
and take them uh really seriously who
basically say
we want to create artificial
consciousness and we're gonna do it as
soon as we know we can do it
so here you have for instance a
statement from stan dehain and his group
in in paris and they want a confluence
of ai
and the cognitive neuroscience of
consciousness
but you also have in tokyo for instance
ryota kanai there's naotsugria
in melbourne and here's the typical
american
way of putting the point michael
graziano from princeton
also a very well-known consciousness
researcher
one could build it for entertainment
value
it would be monumentally cool
i'm not so sure so my main
thesis is a political demand we should
impose a global 30-year moratorium on
all research that knowingly risks or
directly aims
at the creation of artificial
consciousness
and i think there should be a worldwide
ban
on synthetic phenomenology until 2050
or until we know what we are doing
so what is the risk description what do
we want to avoid
i think we could create conscious
suffering on non-biological carrier
systems we could have negative
phenomenology
possibly in a very large number of
individuals think of cascades of copies
or cascades of virtual agents
i call this the explosion of negative
phenomenology
it's not an intelligence explosion but
an explosion of artificial suffering
but there's a problem of epistemic
indeterminacy and i'm going to explain
in a second what this means
we might not even be aware of it because
we don't have a theory of consciousness
basically we don't know what we are
doing in this field
at all so here
is from an article which i'll come back
to later that
will be published in about a week or two
weeks and which will be freely available
for everybody um what is
epistemic indeterminacy
this means that it is not the case
that either we know that artificial
consciousness will
emerge at some point all that we know
that artificial consciousness will never
be instantiated on machines
it is this neonas i think that we have
to deal with in an
ethically sensitive way and in a way
that's evidence-based rational
and intellectually honest and this is
also an important point
i am not saying i have been in this
field for 30 years
this will happen tomorrow and i don't
believe
that it will happen the day after
tomorrow
but my point is that it doesn't matter
what i'm actually thinking
the the problem is this indeterminacy
not that i'm making a statement towards
probability
so let's have a look at the applied
ethics for ai
my background assumption is that what
gives an entity moral status
is the capacity for conscious suffering
and
that in this world reducing suffering
must always have greater priority than
increasing happiness
i'm firmly convinced that there's more
suffering
than joy in this world a brief aside
ai and robot ethics have has a lot of
strong parallels to animal ethics
take this classical quote from arthur
schopenhauer the assumption that animals
are without rights and the illusion
that our treatment of them has no moral
significance
is a positively outrageous example of
western crudity and barbarity
universal compassion is the only
guarantee of morality
so please note that tomorrow's
self-conscious machines have no
representation in
any ethics committee on this planet or
in any political process
but we need to know what that thing is
what is suffering
very simple this uh definition would be
any kind of state the system would
avoid if it had a chance
massive prediction errors in the system
self model
in particular for negative effect
unexpectedly decreasing rates
of prediction error minimization
loss of self-control and negative
balances negatively valued states
in the system's conscious self model
so what i want to do now is i want to
briefly give you
four necessary conditions
for what might be to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas